let's get started by introducing my
esteemed group of colleagues Tim
Wasserman is a program director for the
Stanford advanced project management
program and chief Learning Officer for
IPS learning he is responsible for
developing and managing the Stanford
advanced project management curriculum
through the dynamic partnership of
Stanford University's School of
Engineering and IPs learnings global
team of practitioners tim has been with
the program for over 7 years he's
teaching both on Stanford's campus and
internationally for clients like
Qualcomm Boeing Cisco Pratt & Whitney
and Eaton aerospace as chief Learning
Officer he's also responsible for the
IPS learning product portfolio he has
over 25 years experience development
developing and implementing
enterprise-wide solutions to address the
human capital needs of global fortune
500 companies he's also designed and
implemented large-scale customized
learning and consulting engagements in
areas such as project and program
management leadership development talent
development retention management new
employee stimulus immolation creativity
and innovation and quality methodologies
welcome Tim joining Tim today will be
Ismael all by Johnny Israel is the head
of distance learning organization and
Human Performance at the International
Air Transport Association training and
development Institute he leads I out his
industry professional development
programs in the aviation cargo travel
and tourism sectors which are delivered
to over 25,000 industry specialists and
students every year from IATA
headquarters in Montreal Canada in
addition to his role at IATA his mail is
a member of the Supervisory Board of the
University of Geneva aviation management
MBA and the Stanford aviation management
certificate he also lectures on strategy
and project management at the University
of Geneva and for AI TDI and several
locations welcome miss Neil and with
that I would like to turn the
presentation over to him
Thank You Krista welcome everybody
wherever you are around
it's indeed our pleasure to welcome you
to this webinar to talk about a very
important subject I will start by
talking about the aviation gap sharing
with you the sense of urgency we live in
this industry almost every day at the
beginning of this month I attended an
important conference organized by the
International Civil Aviation
Organization which is the United Nation
body for civil aviation in Montreal
Canada the conference gathered some key
aviation and academic stakeholders from
around the world to try at defining the
aviation profession main competencies
trying to discuss how best the human
capital of this industry can be
developed but most importantly share
ideas on how best we can actively reach
out to the next generation of aviation
professionals to communicate with them
about the wide range of career
possibilities in the aviation industry
but some some of you may ask why
developing the human capital
competencies and reaching out to the
next generation of this industry are
suddenly becoming so important and to
answer this question let me share with
you some important facts according to
according to the 2010 workforce study by
the Aviation Week magazine the study
found that in the larger companies
surveyed those with more than 100,000
employees more than 30% of the workforce
would be eligible to retire in 2012 and
the percentage reached to about 40% by
2014 so so the talent gap in the
industry could be particularly severe in
view of the expected wave of retirement
within the industry which is something
that has been looming for years Airbus
global market forecast for 2010 2029
estimates that almost 20
6,000 new passenger jet liners and
freighters will be needed to meet the
rising demand for flight services Boeing
on the other hand reports that the world
GDP and airline traffic are both
expected to experience positive growth
in the next 18 years in particular the
growth rate of airline traffic is
forecasted to exceed that of the world
economy by 1.8% you also see in the
slide that boeing has forecasted between
2008 and 2012 8 that the world economy
GDP will grow by 3.1 percent
airplane fleet will grow by 3.2 percent
number of passengers by four point one
percent end line traffic represented by
the passenger kilometre will grow by 4.9
percent and cargo traffic will grow by
four five point four percent so
naturally the airline and airport
industries too would need an adequate
talent pipeline to maintain efficiency
and excellence in the face of the
explosion in the demand for their
services so the sense of urgency is
there it's very evident that we have an
existing severe shortage of competent
human resource and their transport
industry in this presentation we will
try with the help of Stanford one of the
world's top universities to form a
competency model in connection with our
air transport industry priorities this
is an important step of the right
direction and it's my pleasure to hand
over to Tim weathermen from Stanford who
will walk us all through the main
competency pillars Thank You Ishmael and
it's not just a significant talent gap
of course as Ishmael has pointed out but
also a potential leadership gap and in
order to to meet this gap really to have
enough future leaders in the pie
I'm ready to assume the leadership roles
when called upon Stanford and IATA have
looked at identifying the key management
skills and competencies that are
particularly critical in the faces not
only today's challenges but the
challenges in the years ahead and really
in order to close this gap what are some
things that can be done today as well as
in the future leadership when asked is
leadership
in art or is it a science think of
leaders that you know that you've
observed that you've had the opportunity
to work with what makes them effective
you know often we hear things like
they're charismatic there's an aura
about them they have a dynamic
personality some might describe these
intangibles as the art of leadership
these are important and what we know
from extensive research on leadership
conducted both here at Stanford and
throughout the world
is that much of leadership is also a
science one that can be studied and it
can be learned and most importantly
successful leaders understand how to
apply these competencies and skills once
identified to the context or the
environment in which the leader exists
in which they live in which they work
today as Ishmael has mentioned we wish
to share some of the insights into these
competencies that we feel are critical
to address
there are many critical competencies
five areas in particular that we've
identified to focus on these groupings
that have the greatest impact if you
will on execution effectiveness
especially in an environment where
project-based work is required to obtain
organizational results in arguably most
work that gets done and all of our
organizations are based on a series of
efforts initiatives or projects that
require cross organizational teams cross
industry teams across geographic
location all teams in order to work
together in those leadership areas that
we want to focus on
are as a large grouping leadership
strategy decision-making innovation and
execution so let's take a look at the
leadership grouping if you will and when
we talk about this leadership grouping
one of the ways to define this is how we
guide and motivate others to work
together towards a common goal four of
the key competencies that are
particularly particular importance
particularly in the environment we're
faced one being vision the ability to
lead the change that invariably comes as
a response to the competitive
environment we're all operating in that
work is previously mentioned really
takes place through teams and finally
communication leadership is particularly
critical because we know that regardless
of the vision regardless of the the
leadership capability our ability to
communicate that to help make the
linkages to articulate the vision to to
motivate our people and to really drive
them towards results is critical and
communication is a key element now
before we one of the things that that
we'd like to do is to look at some
examples that really reinforce the
importance not only of these
competencies but really is a competency
in action example and in the area of
leading with vision not only recognizing
the importance of it but how it can be
communicated ishmael share with us one
particular example sure
I will pick from where you end it Tim
and and let me start by saying
leadership in our industry is about
coping with the constant challenges we
always face almost on daily basis in
this industry so the interesting thing
about the air transport industry is that
it's positively linked with the world
development as as you saw in my
introductory statistics but also the
industry is so fragile and sensitive to
all the different crises all of us fly
all of us are passenger
and we know how the industry almost
collapsed when the h1n1 virus appeared
the volcanic ash in Europe stopped
almost the whole economy and passengers
from flying throughout Europe different
political and economical crisis are very
very linked to our industry with this in
mind the airlines begin to envision the
future of the industry in almost 40
years from now by 2050 the example I
would like to share with you here is a
vision that almost all airlines from
around the world is trying to articulate
in order to have an industry that
eliminates queues with integrated system
ensuring security as we process more
passengers an industry that is very near
to zero accidents an industry that emit
have the carbon dioxide an industry that
operates with almost no delays in global
united skies an industry that ship a
cost and profits equally across the
value chain and finally an industry that
delivered value to investors but this is
more of a dream with a deadline by 2050
let me elaborate further on how the
airlines will leave the way to 2050
there are four cornerstones that have
been agreed as as key elements to
articulate this vision the first
cornerstone is the customer the
passenger the customer is at the center
of the future vision by 2050 we will
have 16 billion travelers and handle 400
million tons of cargo in just a couple
of decades we will see the middle class
nearly triple from the 1.3 billion today
to 3.5 billion people a quarter of which
will be in India and China accommodating
that grow
efficiently will be a challenge for all
parts of the value chain airports air
navigation service providers
manufacturers and even governments the
solution must be strategic and align the
second cornerstone is profitability
efficiency gains never make it to the
bottom line because airlines are
deprived of the commercial freedom to
operate their businesses like a normal
business our poor profitability makes
every shock a fight for survival the
industry hyper fragmentation with about
a thousand sixty-one Airlines as a
result of the bilateral system which
regulates the global aviation industry
the restriction on international capital
also prevent consolidation across
borders the third quarter cornerstone is
infrastructure infrastructure must be
reshaped around the needs of Airlines
the core of the industry value chain
Airport should compete for airline
business based on efficiency commercial
revenues will drive their business we
can see airports paying end lines to
bring shoppers and airports revenue
funding the air traffic management
system air traffic management must also
change we can see 10 global air
navigation service providers replacing
the current about hundred and 80 at half
the cost an example is the single
European sky as you may know would be
the first of the ten global navigation
service providers but this need real
leadership to replace today and
coordinated I would call it by row
critic mess
the fourth cornerstone is is about
powering the industry we cannot just
continue on growing with more
dependencies on fuel we see what's
happening around the world
today's jet fuel cannot sustain air
transport in the long term we must find
a sustainable alternative and our most
promise
the opportunity is biofuels which have
the potential to reduce our carbon
footprint by up to 80% after successful
testing by airline certification is
expected within a year and this requires
strong support and leadership from the
industry and governments investing in
biofuel and green technologies local
production with a judge of the jatropha
camelina IG or even urban waste will
open up economic opportunities in
virtually any location not only will
this secure a future power source for
our industry this will also break the
tyranny of oil and drive economy
development in all parts of the world so
as you can see the best way for our
industry to predict its future is to
build it and through these four
cornerstones and the collaborative work
between the airlines and regulators we
believe that we could shape the industry
by the year 2050
therefore leadership with a strong and
clear vision is a must Tim I hand over
back to you Ishmael
it's a powerful vision that you've
shared and how will we get there is the
obvious next question and how how is the
strategy strategy competencies that are
critical for identifying and
implementing strategy include insight
and not just a gut reaction but really
scanning the environment understanding
gathering data informing your strategy
and with that using that to plan to
create policy and ultimately ensure
alignment as you look to operationalize
that strategy it's really an iterative
process of sharing your strategy
throughout your organization across your
industry and ensuring that feedback
loops are in place so that you can
iterate now strategy you know a good
strategy provides a clear roadmap they
consists of a set of guiding principles
or rules it define two actions P
the organization should take or not take
a good strategy directs the organization
of prioritized activities to prioritize
investments all focused towards
achieving desired goals and results and
strategy drives the portfolio process
and by portfolio process we mean a
decision process that results in which
projects which initiatives which efforts
an organization will invest in which
resources will be applied to those and
at what time those will be applied when
we reflect on this you know the leaders
role in strategy is is not a simple role
but it's rather clear with whether it's
senior leadership who in most
organizations really is chartered with
defining the organization's vision
reflecting on its values and
demonstrating personal commitment it's
all we have levels of leaders in the
organizations who are responsible for
not only demonstrating that commitment
but continually communicating it to
identify the unique position the key
objectives and activities and
translating that we refer to that as
well as the alignment that's critical
it's one thing to have a clearly
articulated strategy it's another to
link that strategy to what people are
accountable for and responsible for on a
daily basis the ability of a leader to
effectively create this linkage helps
keep individuals focused it's also
critical for leaders to recognize that
in this dynamic and global environment
we're all operating in there's not only
a willingness to change course if
necessary but as we do that we're using
metrics we're measuring our progress and
those drive our decision-making and
we're going to talk a bit more about
decision making shortly because that's
another critical key area of confidence
that leaders need to develop but
ultimately using that data to drive
operational improvements and really
create a differentiating approach so
that we can be effective into the future
thank you Sam so indeed the vision was
almost a dream with a deadline the
question we always face and confront in
this industry is how how can we do
the strategy is a real core competency
in our industry and I would like to
share with you an example of how the
industry strategize around a key
priority for the industry that is safety
airlines are focusing among other
strategic initiatives - safety
management systems and training because
the efficient safety management was a
factor in 23% of all incidents or
accidents in 2009 flight crew training
was a factor in 20% of all accidents
crew training was a factor in 58 percent
almost of all long floated or bounced
landing in 2009 which represents about
35% of all runway exertion zhh therefore
the airlines defined a safety strategy
is based on safety program developed in
a teamwork between the airline and the
industry strategic partners with the
focus on areas affecting operational
safety like flight and captain
operations ground handling air traffic
management and cargo handling in
strategy planning data is powerful as
Tim was mentioning the airlines along
with three governmental aviation safety
organization signed an agreement to
launch the global safety information
exchange creating a comprehensive global
information exchange to improve safety
it is the most ambitious private pets
private public safety partnership in the
aviation history as to formalize the
strategic framework yarra representing
the airlines together with the
International Civil Aviation
Organization the United Nation body that
represents the regulator's the US
Department of Transportation have the
three have signed this memorandum of
understanding with the European Union
the commission of the European Union
to create the framework and pass forward
to launch the global safety information
exchange
overall the outcome of the safety
management strategy is very encouraging
let me share with you some of the
results from the benefits of
strategizing in our industry the total
number of accidents decreased by 17% 90
versus a 1 9 109 in 2008 Western Bell
jet how loss rate it decreased by 12%
and the total number of fatal accidents
decreased by 22%
so through strategy planning the
industry is able to address one of its
major concerns that is safety then I
think this is an example I have about
the use of strategy and how this
competency is important in our industry
and I'm sure as you rightly mention
other competencies such as
decision-making are important and I give
it to you to introduce that core
competency absolutely thank you Ishmael
I think it's apparent to all of us when
we consider the the complexity of the
safety program across industry across
government across various functional
operational areas we as leaders are
often handed a strategy and are asked to
execute on it and there are critical
competencies and skill sets that are
required to operationalize that and
really drive to be able to achieve the
results that you shared when we talk
about the area of decision-making
competencies we're really focusing on
those critical decisions that not only
help you know take conflicting goals and
find ways to find commonality amongst
those not only addressing risk but
really good solid decision-making even
if it's not a contentious situation
requires analysis that requires research
it requires really understanding the
context in which the strategy has been
identified and we refer to it on this
particular
slide is market sense but it's really
the larger environment in which you're
operating so when we think about
decision making
just just real quickly you know as
leaders there's different types of
decisions that we face one one of the
areas that we we talk to and teach to in
the program has to do with different
levels of decision making you know there
are reflex decisions those kinds of
decisions that are in the moment that we
face every day how will I spend my time
what meetings will I attend they also
can be things that come up very quickly
customer crisis you know our culture our
organizational perspective the support
we have drives those kinds of decisions
the next level that we refer to is
conscious decisions and those take are
impacted both by time they tend to take
a bit longer they're important but they
may be easy or they may be difficult but
not as important but when we talk about
conscious decisions their decisions that
we typically have developed tools and
processes to support those that are
proven over time and they recognize
certain traps or challenges that we
typically face whether we're thinking
about how to determine funding how and
which ideas to execute and when whether
we're looking at operational issues how
to handle a power outage in a terminal
we typically tend to have approaches
that have been predetermined been tested
checklist driven if you will that can be
effective means for decision making the
most rigorous and in terms of duration
long term ongoing and complex types of
challenges we face the types of
challenges that we'll continue to face
as we look at achieving this vision and
the strategy for the industry those
really are significant issues that take
in-depth exploration and rigor and in
the face of these types of decisions
it's critical that we have an
agreed-upon process one of the processes
that we focus on is really around the
notion
of making a quality decision and what
we've found through extensive research
is that it's as critical to start it's
critical that these six different
factors these six elements are
considered for these very complex
decisions and they're only as good as
their weakest link it's it's an
iterative process we're validating each
step of the way with committees with
sponsors with key stakeholders but it's
critical that we explore each of those
very quickly it really begins with the
appropriate frame what is it we're
deciding we often look at a problem and
there's a high degree of disagreement
even about how we articulate and frame
that problem and it's critical to get
the appropriate people together who are
going to be working on this problem and
agree to that frame next is looking at
alternatives you know what are our
choices what are different creative but
doable alternatives often organizations
look at the blue sky kind of a creative
open your mind and don't be constrained
by what's doable that's a very effective
and creative process but there is a
point during the second set the second
element where you really need to start
to then weigh in what is doable what do
we know collecting mean of meaningful
information being aware of biases that
exist in the information that's provided
to us and then looking at clear value
and trade-off what consequences do we
care about both negative and positive
what are we willing to live with and
what do we absolutely need to make sure
there is no ambiguity in those decisions
and then really checking our thinking
and that could be validated through
people who are not part of the process
it can be validated through experts it
can be validated through this notion of
novice consulting people who aren't
experts in our area but we bring in we
present potential solutions to them and
we get their reaction to that solution
and ultimately can we all align and
commit
to act together and particularly in the
kinds of issues that the industry is
facing the types of extreme challenges
that the industry has faced in recent
years and will continue to face it's
critical that this cross industry cross
government cross functional and
operational decision-making process is
utilized so that there is agreement and
these very challenging and difficult
issues are addressed in a meaningful way
fish male I think a great example has to
do with security indeed and we asked the
question you outlined at 10 what is what
are we deciding the pond security
remains an increasing area of interest
and concern worldwide among other things
of course proactive and comprehensive
decision-making are just the name of the
game in our industry in order to cope
with the rising and diverse challenges I
mentioned before as a concrete example
as Tim mentioned security in the recent
years we have seen growing the issue of
sustainable growth with the world
economy is definitely jeopardized by
security terrorists and criminals have
long view deviation as a target for
attack and exploitation the tragic
events of September 11 and the ether
plot of August 2006 are telling
reminders of the threat facing this
industry but airlines are committed to
keeping the global skies safe and secure
and so the Allies met as an example and
made several important decisions in this
area the decision number one was to
institutionalize the government industry
cooperation once again what Tim was
mentioning the private public
interaction in order to make a very well
informed decision thinking about the
consequences that that Tim showed us in
his
presentation this would allow security
policies to be written with the benefit
of airline operational experience the
second decision in the area of security
security was about implementation
recognizing that one-size-fits-all
regulation with all numerical targets
will not secure a complex global
industry government must work with
industry to define practical
implementation measures for their
security targets the third decision made
by by the airlines was that the
passenger data again once again the
analytical point of decision is
important make passenger data collection
and sharing more efficient information
to break down and tenant silos and
create a single data collection and
sharing program that could serve as a
model for implementation by other
governments and then we move into the
fourth decision which is harmonized
across borders governments must talk to
each other to ensure that one country's
requirement do not conflict with another
country slow we see how we are treated
differently from one immigration office
to the other around the world but also
from one security checkpoint to the
other and finally the next generation
checkpoint was agreed upon
along with optimizing the capabilities
of current screening technologies we
must begin to look at future checkpoints
that combine technology and intelligence
we need a checkpoint system that that
focus on finding bad people not just
that object they about five critical
agreement points show how collective
collaborative decision-making is indeed
a critical competency for the survival
of the industry them
what one size doesn't fit all I think
that's really a critical point when we
talk about our next area of competence
that's critical for leaders and that
that's really innovation increasingly
the challenges we're facing require
innovative solutions and our ability to
think into the future to what-if to
really challenge creatively ourselves
and often an environment that's been
built in an industry that's been built
on standardization and with good reason
the it's critical that we do extensive
risk assessment it's critical that from
an engineering perspective we have some
solve some of the most complex
engineering problems in the world in
this industry and along with this this
technical rigor also is a requirement
that we continue to innovate and think
of things in new and different ways in
essence you know we have to look for
creative solutions for problems that
haven't even been identified yet the
notion of foresight creativity there's a
innovative effort underway at Stanford
University around the notion of design
thinking which is really taking a
cross-disciplinary approach to
challenges not only from a technical
perspective and an operational
perspective but bringing in all views in
our industry whether it's the customer
whether it's key stakeholders whether
it's non-traditional areas that we might
consider and then part of this design
approach this design innovative thinking
is to prototype to to try things to
learn to be quick to try something
gather data and make adjustments and
move on and that culmination of that
prototyping when strung together can
help create very complex problems in
some rather creative ways I'm not going
to spend a lot of time I just wanted to
highlight there's a gentleman by the
name of Jeffrey Moore who's worked very
closely with a number of our Stanford
faculty who studied innovation and
technology companies in emerging markets
in fact his latest book dealing with
Darwin was at the request of John
Chambers the CEO of Cisco Systems to
look at innovation and he really helps
us Moore's work helps us better grasp
complexity and what innovation means in
a flat world and at being the world we
all operate and where we are so
interconnected regardless of
geographical location and how innovation
impacts us all what can we do to help
answer tough questions you know what
type of innovation would be most
strategically important what evidence
will we use to guide the decisions what
decision-making process will we use
there's some common themes I think that
you're hearing from Ishmael and I
throughout and and really as we look at
those leadership challenges and the
leadership competencies that are created
it's very difficult to decouple these
they all occur together and and it's
it's critical that we're thinking
holistically about those challenges but
in terms of innovation just one other
quick thought to share with you what we
know from research is that organizations
really have four different types of
strategic outcomes that they made may
need to consider when they're
considering innovation one is what Moore
calls a differentiation and that's how
can we be different from our competitors
and many of our individual organizations
within the industry are considering
those kinds of approaches differentiate
how might one airline differentiate
itself itself from another another
approach is more refers to as
neutralization and that's really we're
simply responding to competitive
situations and much of his work is in a
in a highly competitive environment but
there's insight for us because the third
area that he recognizes is critical and
where a lot of innovation occurs is the
the area of what he calls productivity
or enhancing an organization's or an
industry's own productivity and he
really discusses this operational
excellence as being central to to an
organization's strategy and and we feel
it's particularly appropriate in the
aviation industry and particularly in
these cross
across industry challenges that we're
facing as we're working together it's
critical that we really are looking in
the area of operational excellence for
innovative solutions unfortunately the
the fourth area the red area most
companies only achieve that area they're
really the unwanted time in terms of
waste of time and money by focusing on a
failed approach so so the key around
innovation is really to get very clear
on what type of strategic outcome you're
facing and then to employ some some
creative processes in order to achieve
those Ishmael yes thanks for sharing
these interesting strategic outcomes
statistics indeed in our industry and if
I focus on the airline in particular
there are not much differences anymore
in terms of strategy at the end of the
day many of them provide almost the same
what the industry is facing is a lot to
do with productivity and when I say
productivity is the effectiveness and
efficiency of the industry so despite
the importance of our industry in
connecting the world economy and
demonstrating the real meaning of a
global village the matter of fact is
that our industry is one of the least
profitable ones compared to other
industries in a world where fuel prices
a major cost element as an example is we
see uncontrollable the ability to
innovate and think creatively I'm using
your code term here is the only way to
survive in the in the air transport
industry therefore there is an
increasing need to improve efficiency
and effectiveness toward increased
productivity let me take an example
which is a program we call simplifying
the business initiative it's a strategic
initiative that is all about innovation
thinking and traditionally thinking
outside the box trying to cross
industries and share best practices from
industries even outside the
but to see why an example the banking of
financial industry is making a lot more
than our industry and so so technology
has been spotted as one of the key areas
where our industry is lagging behind so
this program simplifying the business is
aimed to change the way the air
transport industry operates resulting in
better services for the passenger as
well at a lower cost for the industry
the program serves the industry up to 18
point 1 billion every year in terms of
cost savings the program as I say them
fascitis in the role of technology and
accelerating the passengers travel
enhancing the experience of a passenger
in an airport despite the rising
security measures at the airports which
I have mentioned before so while the
industry needs to focus on the core
operational activities and that's where
decision-making is an important
competency getting out of the box
remains the most important way to
survive and go beyond the day-to-day
operations in this norm two or three
initiatives or examples I would like to
share with you that has been implemented
already one is the electronic ticketing
today many of us travel around the world
and maybe some of you like myself have
traveled in in the past ten years and so
that the way we're traveling is very
different we used to print or go to
travel agencies print a ticket and take
a coupon and if it's lost it's a big
disaster and then you you basically held
hostage for this coupon today the
electronic ticketing is available online
you can even upload it in your mobile
check-in online and and simply present
yourself at the security in the airport
this is one example of how the use of
technology has been fundamental to
enhance the
and your experience but also in terms of
cost saving I can tell you a lot about
three billion dollar has been achieved
in terms of saving the cost of printing
and distributing for the industry in the
first year of launch not ignore the fact
that this is a very environmentally
friendly initiative so the value
proposition is clear to all parties
involved another one is the common use
self service and this is something you
see today in many airports around the
world you go you don't need any more to
queue in a long line to wait for an
officer to check you in you can do that
as I said online but also you can use
the common use of service which is by
the way an initiative that we borrowed
from the banking industry all of us cash
money from the ATM machines so it's a
similar technology we have taken from
outside our immediate industry these are
just examples I wanted to share with you
and how important is to innovate but
also to go outside the box in terms of
industry and thinking traditionally with
that I give Tim the floor maybe to tell
us about execution thank you thank you
Ishmael and some great examples of
looking outside the industry you know at
the end of the day we're all ultimately
accountable for execution for achieving
results for the implementation of the
strategy and there's a variety of ways
we do that in a variety of
considerations that weir's need to focus
on project portfolio management that the
notion that work gets done through a
series of projects and there that
requires an understanding of the
criteria it requires an understanding of
the priorities it requires an
understanding of the resources and the
funding available to execute on those
and in many cases deciding it's as
important to decide what not to do as it
is to decide what to do so that those
items that you do choose to focus on are
executed effectively there's a lot of
other issues that come into play when
we're looking at actually executing
these strategies and implementing the
innovative ideas that we come up with
you know the culture
of our organization as well as the
culture that's part of our industry and
nationalistic cultures and alike culture
is a very complex issue typically we
come up with great ideas and in order to
implement those it requires negotiation
another key element a key skill area
that's required in order to effectively
execute and the leaders ability to
negotiate with key stakeholders and and
manage others over whom they may not
have direct authority but need their
support and ultimately tying that into
to operations
I'm not going to go into this in a lot
of detail but I just wanted to let you
know another resource that we rely
heavily on and a significant amount of
research that has been done in support
of the Stanford IATA program is
something called the strategic execution
framework and it's a model that really
helps describe the link from the
ideation the purpose the the long-range
intent of an organization or an industry
you know who are you what do you stand
for where are you heading
it also takes into consideration what we
call the nature domain or the issues of
culture of structure and and based on
organizational culture what is the
context in which you are trying to
operate and contribute the third domain
to the right is what we call the vision
domain and that's where we start to
translate the ideation the longer the
long term kind of vision to a more
tactical vision and we set goals and
metrics to measure against and all of
that informs the strategy what is it
that we need to create and we've talked
about vision today we've talked about
strategy we've looked a bit at portfolio
in terms of that is where strategy
really gets translated into action and
then through projects and programs and
ultimately translating into operations
we identify what it is that we need to
to focus on and how to
on that you know as a leader looking to
effectively implement operational
improvements looking for consistent
standards it's critical to ensure that
all these factors listed in the
framework are considered and addressed
we found that one of the the most
critical success factors for leaders
today is their ability to connect the
dots if you will to be able to help
their their team members their
organizations and others that they're
working with across organization and
across industry to really see the
linkages from the very highest level if
you will from the ideation and the
vision all the way down to the
operational level and we'd like to share
one more example of what can happen when
all of these domains are in alignment as
we operationalize a vision and our
industry is no different from the
examples Tim was highlighting and
sharing with us many of the strategic
initiatives failed in our industry
because of poor implementation there is
an importance on strategy thinking and
planning as a core competency for the
industry and that's very important
because without it we cannot build
frameworks and we looked at at the
example of the safety management system
how the airlines met and decided on the
key pillars for the safety management
system and built that strategy plan so
why don't we carry on with the same
example and I can share with you the
rest of the story which is how then that
strategy being translated into reality
the other operational safety audit we
call it iota a program has been designed
to manage the implementation of the
safety strategy framework by all
airlines worldwide using strict project
management methodology for successful
implementation today the IATA operations
safety audit program is an
internationally recognized and accepted
evaluation system design
to assess the operational management and
control system of any airline worldwide
the principle are designed to conduct
audits in a standardized manner but that
requires a rigid and strict project
management discipline benefiting the
aviation industry so this is this this
discipline of execution has benefited
the industry as a whole in reducing the
cost of audit and resources required for
the airlines and regulators it also
helped continuous updating of the
standards to reflect regulatory
provisions and the course evolution of
best practices within the industry a
quality audit program under the
continuing stewardship of I ala
accredited audit organization who are
actually the project management offices
if you want are trained and formally
qualified to implement and to audit
these standards and accredited training
organization with structure auditors and
training courses this have been a
success story as I mentioned and it's
not because we built the strategy it's
also because we took it even a step
further and translate it into a real
real action for the industry
thanks Ishmael so I think in closing
around what we've been discussing so far
relative to the importance and the
leaders role what hopefully we've been
able to share with you is not only some
of those key competencies that are
critical but at the end of the day
what's critical for the leader is to
understand the strategy in the direction
to be effective at translating that and
to both inspire their organization and
the individuals that they're working
with as well as provide direction and
guidance on how to achieve results and
at the end of the day of course it's
about ensuring the results that we
commit to and doing those in an
effective and competent way so these are
just some of the critical competencies
for leaders in the industry today we'd
now like to pass the the ball if you
will back to Carissa who's going to
share a little bit about a little more
about the program that's available to
all of you well thank you so much Tim in
Israel before I describe a bit about how
you can learn more I'd like to remind
you that we will have a Q&A session in
just a few moments so we'd encourage you
to please ask questions for both Tim and
Ismail as we proceed here so at the
Stanford center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for over 40 years
and so we have reasonable experience
creating educational programs to address
the career long learning needs of
professionals managers and executives in
many industries around the world we at
Stanford are pleased to be offering the
Stanford IATA aviation management
certificate program in partnership with
IATA training and development institute
and we believe that the certificate is
quite a unique offering because it
blends the industry practical experience
from experts at IATA and IPS learning
with the Stanford darian research
resulting in the truly rigorous and
advanced program that's been designed to
address the competencies you heard about
today and in order to create the future
leaders of the aviation industry we
created this program because as you
heard today whether you work in airline
customer-service sales and marketing
network planning or air transport
services there is a leadership gap in
the aviation industry around aligning
business management techniques with
specific challenges for that 2050 vision
for aviation that you heard about and
you can see here the resulting
curriculum there are three IATA courses
focused on aviation and three courses
from Stanford focused on how to deliver
on your business priorities the program
is also delivered via distance learning
and must be completed within 12 months
and the
both of this curriculum is a Stanford
aviation at Stanford IATA aviation
management certificate this issued
jointly by Stanford University Stanford
center for professional development and
IATA as well as a Navy MP designation
now a VMP holders are required to renew
their certification every three years
and we require some additional education
one course from Stanford and one course
from IATA to maintain that certification
here you can see the program curriculum
and the required six courses Air
Transport fundamentals provides a
strategic 360 degree view of the
industry with airport operations diving
into specifics around executing those
strategies converting strategy into
action and mastering the project
portfolio will provide a conceptual
framework for aligning your business
units specific initiatives with your
strategic objectives and how to ensure
that those initiatives have the right
resources and can be completed on time
airline revenue management provides
strategies for pricing and decision
making to optimize revenues and
leadership for strategic execution
addresses key leadership challenges for
those responsible for executing
strategies while faced with change a
problem ever so common in Air Transport
so what we try to do in creating this
program was offer courses via very
flexible delivery options so you can
access them 24 hours a day seven days a
week
and these are available both via ebook
and online via streaming video you'll
also find some contact details and some
pricing information here and we
encourage you to send us email or ask us
questions and so now we'd like to take a
moment to conduct a poll if you could
please we really appreciate your
feedback if you could indicate your
level of interest in the Stanford IATA
certificate we'd really appreciate it
okay I think we've got some some good
responses thank you so much and with
that
I'd like to facilitate our
question-and-answer period here
so if Timur Ismail can answer this
question for me does this framework
apply to all professions within the
industry and to all management levels um
I can maybe tell me if you allow me I
can't answer that one absolutely so so
thanks for the question Chris I think
it's a it applies to all professions
whether whether it's someone who works
in an airport airline civil aviation
authority from a regulation point of
view ground handling company even even I
would say cargo or even travel agency
this applies to everybody because the
model as you saw is about developing a
human capital in an industry that is
more in need of anyone else I think Air
Transport now does it apply to all level
of professions I would say yes with
different concentration and focus on the
different areas so if you are an
entry-level profession you you don't
need necessarily to to focus a lot on
the strategy or the leadership you need
to understand them contribute to them
but maybe your role would be more into
the execution and and decision-making
and the other elements so you need to
look at this with with with a clear
understanding but also map to your own
reality and try to develop them all at
the same time if possible Thank You
Ismail so one other question here we
have a couple more questions where does
the responsibility for portfolio
management so it was in an organization
well I'll address that Carissa portfolio
management it really varies by by
organization some organizations at the
more strategic executive level will
focus on identifying strategy and then
beginning to identify how to break that
strategy down and build a portfolio in
other word
there's a waterfall approach that's
utilized whereby that strategy is
articulated up and down the organization
and then individuals and organizations
from throughout provide their requests
if you will their their aspects to
executing on those key strategic
initiatives and the projects and the
programs that would be required to
execute on those at the end of the day
what we know is is critical or a couple
of factors one that there is a clearly
defined and understood portfolio process
that's as critical as determining and
clearly defining who the owner is of
that process but there's something
called fair process that's a concept
that suggests that if people believe
that the process used to make decisions
particularly portfolio decisions about
where to focus efforts on investments
and activities if there's a belief that
that is a fair and equitable process
that key stakeholders all have a say in
that and that there's some clearly
identified criteria that's articulated
and is very transparent to an
organization then those are some of the
key elements required for an effective
portfolio process I guess the last thing
I'd say is that we have lots of examples
where even individual leaders or
managers all the way down to an
individual project level employee some
best practices around portfolio
management in order to make decisions
about resources and what they will focus
on in prioritization so it is something
that can be applied in many levels in
the organization
thank you Tim so our final question I
believe is for Israel so how does this
program differentiate itself from the
a.m. PAP offered by ACI ni k oh sure so
all of us together collectively because
we work all in the same industry and as
I mentioned we work closely with Cael
the objective is to develop human
capital but in different ways so the
program we are having is addressing the
wide spectrum of
the air transport industry so it has you
so when Carissa was presenting the
curriculum we're addressing airports but
not only airports and lines and the 360
degree view on the air transport
fundamentals on the other hand the the
program which is actually called for
people who doesn't know what is it it's
the airport management professional
accreditation program from the name it
focuses on mainly Airport related
competencies so they are both aiming at
the same objective which is to develop
the human capital ours is more
industry-wide this one is focused on the
airport profession itself by christen
well thank you at eminence mail I'm
sensitive to time here and I've noted
that there are a number of questions
still in the queue and so we'll continue
to stay online and answer those via chat
but I just I wanted to remind you first
I want to thank Tim and Ismail for a
great presentation today I wanted to
remind you that you may now print a PDF
of the slides by selecting a print to
PDF option in the lower navigation bar
and remember to look for an email that
will alert you when this webinar is
available to watch online you can feel
free to share it with others
and so I just like to thank you all for
joining us today we really appreciate
your time and I hope you have a good
morning or afternoon or evening
depending on where you are in the world
thank you so much